hello and welcome to this video playing
Keisha Keisha from India so what do we
have oh yes we will pass Spanish
exchange he's taking a long time when
what's what the heck it's a fairly new
account or nothing particularly
suspicious could a decent connection a
you never know maybe just as doorbell
rang or something like that happened to
me as well
I think this is what is normally played
but I'm not I don't know the details all
that well or more precisely not at all
so what what is happening here i think
this year this is the move or we should
be six i think also here why does
playing mostly for the development I
think so i'm just going to open it up
[Music]
f6 so you're taking on e5 doesn't look
right but maybe this 493 asking the
bishop what's what it is doing f5 is a
nice square for for the night
potentially like 93 bishop age 59 f five
this could be could be good he's
covering this so
I won't like a a four is probably not
doing all that much good is b3 maybe a
move for Bishop a three I could be an
interesting idea let's try it like a
bishop a3 now I mean okay first of all I
can do this I don't I don't know if he
wants to take okay I don't know if you
wanted but he has taken okay now now
actually to f5 why not Bishop e3 also
was possible that Knight to f5 is right
quite tempting
how he is taking ages him okay let's put
it where it belongs yeah queen geforce
already already a bit annoying there
the typical motif or the night on g6
it's not easy here for black let's see
Bishop yeah h5 each 597 night h6 King
edge aid doesn't does not win looks
pretty pretty awkward but it doesn't
seem to win right away I can't play
Bishop b3 I mean one thing that I do
threaten is some kind of fatigue on e5
at the end to take e 5
just drug ok
just preparing group do you want I don't
think the direct direct ideas were that
good Bishop h6 was also funny idea pawn
takes h5 but Queen f7 was always
covering things
yeah cream / sir can be expected so this
and now probably taking 95 Queen at 59
f5 Queen f5 should win de pont if he
takes like FTX I am Bishop g5 also it
looks pretty awkward also I have
absolutely no idea how we will ever
manage to not lose on time I hope the
one but ok I get the default that cannot
be bad
f of a 5 a-4 it's not that bad not that
bad I don't have that much am all right
i say this valley it is very awkward
fortunately cannot play kingly 3 C 4 C 5
I can completely boxing this n check
check I know he makes a million moves
when it's absolutely too late check
black forfeits on time yeah I'm not
really satisfied with the way the
position turned out to be we call it
looks really awkward and I somehow
didn't didn't get get all that much the
direct age five yeah was possible it
didn't help all that much yeah I can
this looks nice but there's no way
forward as you can perpetual him and if
I would have traded already here you
would just take the 75 and just have a
healthy extra pawn but you cannot hear
take first we can but this is good for
him so it wasn't all that clear and here
just taking what's good okay no that
looks pretty nice I did not evaluate
this correctly I thought that would be
very good for me but he's got that a 5a
for I mean the engine still gives me an
advantage was just probably true it I
just felt there should be more but
somehow there wasn't yeah and ce4 I
should prepare better with a 3 in 32 bit
of shock
bit of a scramble now it doesn't make
much sense to analyze that I said wonder
I mean he made a million moves with his
two seconds Jack really not some moves
okay thanks for watching